all right what's going on everybody
welcome to another another python 3
basics tutorial video in this video what
we're going to be talking about is
python lists versus tuples so they can
be kind of confusing at times and you
might consider a tuple a list
and you might not understand why you're
unable to do things with it so
the grand if both of them are lists
right
you know by the definition of a list you
know in the world both of them are lists
but a tuple is immutable and a list is
mutable and what that means is a tuple
we can't change it okay so once you
define that tuple you can't be modifying
that tuple a python list on the other
hand we can modify we can add values
remove values change values
sort the you know order and all kinds of
stuff so
um that's the difference how do we
define them
well the definition of a tuple is
basically anything whereas we could say
x equals five six two and six okay
that's a tuple because we don't have
anything around it so it's a tuple the
other way that you can define a tuple
would be x equals and then using these
round brackets
five six two six these are both tuples
okay now then you've got a python list
so we can say 5 or y equals and then we
can say 5 6 2 6. that's a python list
and the only reason or the only way that
we know that's a list is with the square
brackets and python just recognizes this
as the case so
what's the point of this so
a lot of times like in my programming i
rarely use tuples for anything other
than sequence unpacking which we'll show
in a moment
and that's really it
so
but there might be other times where you
want to maybe pass some information
through also if you have a list not a
python list but let's say a list of data
that you know you don't want to change
or you want to make sure it doesn't
change then you would you would use a
tuple because the tuple is going to
generate faster and it's going to be
iterated through faster than a python
list that's about it so anyway a popular
example of when people use tuples would
be something like this so say you have
an example function
and this example function after a bunch
of code blah blah blah it returns a 15
and a six so it returns two values
what you want to do sometimes is you
want to say x y equals example font and
what that's going to do is it's going to
assign the returned values of this
example function to x into y
and it's very important that it stays in
that order okay
so this is why
a tuple is important in some scenarios
now this isn't the only scenario that
someone would use a tuple again if you
wanted to iterate through a huge list
in quotes like not a python list but a
huge uh group even groups not a good
word it's very hard to find a word that
isn't like something that's defined in
python but anyway a huge assortment of
data
you're going to want to use a tuple if
you don't want it to change or you don't
need it to change ever and so on but if
you want it to change and be mutable
you're going to want to use a list
so
um
that's about
it at least with a tuple
for example let's say let's just delete
all of this here and we'll leave this
okay with a tuple let's say you want to
reference data within this uh
group of
assortment of data i'm having such a
hard time picking a phrase so we can do
x um
one like this and what this means so
you've got the print x as in x here and
then we've got square brackets and then
one what this is saying is we want to
know the
the one i guess is the better way to say
it the one element because basically
when you have a list or a tuple or
whatever a group of data
the values when they are exploded let's
say into all of their little indexes so
each one of these numbers here has its
own index
and the indexes start at a value of zero
not one zero so this is the zero with
element this is the first element
second
element in the third element okay so
they start at zero it's kind of hard to
get used to at first but you'll get used
to it so now with that tuple we can
still cut we can still um
ask questions against the tuples so the
first fifth element was a six sure
enough no problem we can also do
basically the exact same thing so we'll
just copy paste we'll say y the first
actually let's say the second element so
we should get a two or six and then a
two sure enough
um so that's how we can reference data
the other thing that we could do
obviously uh would you know you can
print you know want and then so y just
y2 we can say y2 and y3 that we want to
print out
like that
and that's really it so um those are
just this is a very basic notion of
accessing data that's within a tuple or
a list
the next video is going to be much more
in depth as far as list manipulation
accessing all this searching and all
this fun stuff like i said generally
you're going to use a tuple
i guess i can't really speak for
everybody at least for myself i rarely
use tuples except for sequence unpacking
that's really about it
otherwise i just use a list now if
you're looking for efficiency or you
have a huge list it might make sense to
use a tuple but again if you use like a
generator uh which we'll probably cover
later on uh the difference i don't
really think is that big so anyway
you'll probably find yourself using
lists more they're much more programming
friendly and oftentimes you are going to
want to
uh modify a list so
anyway enough on that we will cover that
in the next video if you guys have any
questions or comments about this video
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time